The woman who puts on the fire The
fan sushi is a service is this finger
Wasabi all is Puten no Puden Mice In
front of the secret spot Gozendo Soma Owner Chef Nail Art Lutan Line 3
Dormer
Now 26 years indirect  I'm doing sushi, but the influence is
that I see flips in various 3s Well, only various seed prefectures are performing
Well I will judge
this restaurant bar of love this restaurant bar Crown Win New York It's different.
Slip Flame Slow Katsumai sushi restaurant
If you like 3
Percent ppu Segping is a tip at Every Hahn, and I believe that it is better for the customer
to eat it by touching it with a finger rare hand
yes  Shrine King Palette Renzada ime bar s for men topics
for murder Book owner Shrine modeling
Pure
memento Cats It's good, it's
high, so it's a rest dance sushi bar Spaberick Just press
Dutch Wife Dew Ladies everybody Bochin Nakahime First of all, by all means  Red Mud
Burner Fighting
we are Weber seo firm Overre r 2 pure Half
is to do
La Good Good Good London Meal This movie and stop to xj
It's
a meeting at the top of
this maze nos 2
dns paint nun wedding house maker egg
pi ke
ba
egg is
one of the most important jobs among the 5 companies, but it took me 5 years to get to the egg 4  For a year,
cleaning, making tea, 3 cleaning the
restaurant, etc. were the main things, but
10 years is a little overkill, but it is certainly very important.
Pull his point fishing spedan.  Ms. Evli Buddy Fine Knowledge Bullet b
4 s 10 Driving ss 2
Person's Sex While
only nice was born, mail clearly with woman  oooo This kind of
certain fur buddy fight price is Defender 2 sweet Gieser
Scarlos Creator Game Overboard 3 Beads
Defending Franz
price
One and a sword nomenclature I'm a blowfish license is very important
Well I'm a blowfish in Tokyo and Kyoto
If you don't have it, you can never cook at the store.
There are many kinds
of puffer fish, and even one puffer fish is not good for him.  There are some things that you can eat, and
basically you can't eat all the internal organs
.
It's okay to touch it, but
basically all the separate sushi should be done according to the regulations of that Japanese health center
.
Sat down with Mother's Good Good
Guardin Re-Aptina Box Will 6 cases
hiding Neck Tape special person Khan pickup
dc Zerg Form Good
Already Fashionable Realism 4 Run Pouch This preparation
is not perfect at all, but well  It's about 6 out of 10 points, but it's a slippery Bailey
store manager. I
'm not too strong, I'm holding it so that it contains air with one hand.
Fish Price
Bayliss Software s how to Too Basser be with
miku Master beer with Kazuo b Broken by pressure rice
Rayfan Service Fish Life Hansard Catch rice
the finger Before and after Starville Only
sushi is basic  It is an absolute requirement to put air in the rice and hold it, so do
not tighten it too tightly.
It is an absolute requirement. Over 9 Keeper sense 4 rest
Able is a priority for dogs.
o do I do
n't attach it.
Put the fish on the person and take a walk. 2 Fingers are stable os 2 Fingers
Well, there are various techniques, but the one I learned from my
parents was to return the book.  That's probably the oldest
way to grip
it. It's done with the
five hands of the Five Emperors, but
my master says that it's only the ego in front of the board that it takes more than the boat
.
I think it's because I think it's very important to assume that the fingerprints of both needles
and the human body temperature aren't reflected in the fish by touching a little less, because that
's the world of sushi-I
can't comment.  I mean, the world of manga is anything
and it's very difficult to comment. Yes
web 34 s inc
I think it's very difficult in the raw state to just fall in love with the fish.
When I take this much for the pillars and my teacher, I think it's
relatively easy to do this with all the power after grilling and baking it for the first time.
i don d 1 Fave e 250 people s d Saber  anos
fish
this fp Suo Friend
Nacky Naki Leeds for you
Zubezuda Boss Vegetable Knife Preparation Antiru Service That kind of
Zinger 7 f There are
various types of sushi plates, but my
4 wins are all taught to use different knives  I received tuna rain hard
white meat 3 times white I use different knives for all different fish Good child fisheye
changing No Fuchu no Sumo wrestling Phil Izumo Stick
Well Katsushi Izumo is
there
[Applause]
maybe Sunny Degree Bar Brown Meety Doubler
Knife agree Darts Ame Ise
are you doing my menu How
to do ex
Baby Empire compared to Spiders Inside Meety Basically they have a lot of really delicious horses 3 big elements
so
well  It has a strong scent, and after we hurt it and baked
it, it's wonderful to be with the sushi.
oh dear
There is also a way to say that by hitting when there is sushi, it destroys Nagano cells and then
when cooking, the cells are destroyed and
it becomes softer. For example, in Spain, it freezes once and then uses it after freezing.
I think that's the same way that all the cells are destroyed in the same way. In Japan, hitting is a long time ago.
[Music] It's a
game in the eyes.
Navigating sushi Kurobe is also called Hapi I
can't use the robbery area, so the reason why I don't use it
is that the smell of gas is the most important.
I don't have an explanation because it tastes different. Well, I
don't even use a good sushi restaurant that I know in Tokyo
.
[Music]
Grainer sm Pointing
in japan
after Sushi Onna Toba Service is  a is also on the way out asiken to the London
War Turn Government Miuta Saint xo Buster Beef Sauce Aveda reason Condition
Ainu Family Percent Sushi Restaurant Newsing Fresh Tomorrow's Baths
are a believer 22 Already Bigs everybody Friend
Frozen Powder Come on b
Mile Restaurant  New flavor server import from japan
darts aroma flavor sasada nox sushi ameberg sushi
ab com n bass 4
no defense 2 pesh beach area lumbar rice
3 sushi politics
It tastes like
a stallion with the
sushi
rice on top.
pain to do as my
se 4 t Family Snow Lager Totou Tandise Sushi Ah
Fish A profitable wife chair cd reel b Early morning top
Elvis 8 seems to be f Touch raw + Firth is c  omplete with
stone 2 to do your photo by
tingufefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe  Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe
Fefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefefe 4 t 5 t Glider
by Tin 2 Flavor Tea Girl
Make your needs when you put it out  Sense with my fadism ipad 3 s 4
Mies good
Would you like to make Ocarina?
Actually, it's the end of the rice, and it's
actually better to have a spoon date,
so
I think it's completely different from the crispy aftertaste when you eat it.
There is one, but
depending on the department
, I sometimes think that it is better
to scratch it with a spoon like this.
Tech Frontier Guest looks nice
Luke's is also la sushi
this rarry I woman tissue roseberry
er Bale wedding movie tn 10 j Bailey
On the other hand, usb has 4 shots Sugar 1 party So
4 one ok
Well  Almost
sushi is
about 80%
rice, so rice is very important in the process of transferring the owner. Well, even in the process, the process of mixing rice with rice
is a very nervous
emperor
.  Do not touch and
fill the male with as much air as possible.
For that purpose,
it is better to cut as little as possible. Cut rice 4 d 5 d Green
road tm 4th place
The day and the code i The flight to take Stingray is not me  I
'm telling you to flatten Miyajima as much as possible and reduce the number of touches.
4 s 2
and cute
Oh that's not the case if she knows the reason and cuts that line, but
it's just cut completely so some fish have different limes depending on the part
and I understand it properly  If you don't cut it, the texture will get worse when you eat it,
and the customers
will feel uncomfortable.
In the interface, Hiko 5
Mae mss Omakase is ping t Make up
the beat factor question
If you complete the house couple Pickles Medium fried rice Rice with a good score 4
Abduction is an all-weather radio machine Total balance
Hime Tinko Iku
Noru The sound of the wave In love with rice  Pierce Par
us III Arles All Swing dsc 1 Roll Tape Lati Babys Security
Line 2 Teardown
Ole Deep Capreip Oosu Absence
Sea Zoo Lady Standing in the
Flames Control Tempura Fried Rice +4 f 8 dc
Bouberlayer Gligar s faze Edge Advisor In Earth  Japan s
6 wins 9 losses
Yes Fo 3 Impose listener kind Gligar
Nekusunets Generation i see Rag next next Flavor
rim bottom
witch no Fisk for you i never by internet
No water point Sakura Rei Touch fried rice
vics knife is always Leica
Inumae Extension Dawn Well, I'm in a foreign country so it's hard
to buy people who haven't been to Japan I think it's very difficult to buy, but
I basically don't really trust that fried rice.  So, after all, seeing and touching with your own hands,
what is the best? For example, there are already 100,200 types of the same goat fried rice, so
when you choose this one of them, you still touch it yourself.
I think it's best to touch it and buy it by yourself. I've been doing it for 26 years,
so I'm no longer satisfied with ready-made products, so I can't help it, so I'm doing this kind of
magic.  I have a force with almost no hits. Thank you for watching Osaka Tea
. A After this, click the video Kuricorder to burn it.